good afternoon everyone
i'm dr miller and the scp we're going to
be looking at today
is scp-2032
object class ketter
special containment procedures scp-2032
is to be kept in a standard humanoid
cell
at site-6-3 four armed guards are to be
posted outside of scp-2032
cell at all times to prevent false
information from being planted in his
belongings
all requests made by scp-2032 within
reason
are to be accepted pending review and
written consent of a level 3 researcher
newspapers documenting recent world
events aren't to be delivered to
scp-2032's containment cell
daily scp-2032 is to be given two 16
milligram capsules of galantimine
daily provided with the morning and
dinner meals
at approximately 8 30 every morning
scp-2032 is to be given a 100 milligram
subcutaneous injection of anakinra
provided that the joint inflammation
does not restrict movement scp-2032 is
given two hours daily of
physician-approved exercise
and socialization with the staff of
site-6-3 so long as he is accompanied by
a nurse
following a mild stroke scp-2032
is on a mechanical ventilation apparatus
is confined to a wheelchair
and is no longer allowed to leave his
containment cell
the cell has been refurnished with
life-support equipment
description scp-2032 appears to be an
elderly man of middle eastern origin
his true age and ancestry are not
currently known
although plausible records would
indicate connection to
caliphate circus ce
although scp-2032 has an apparent
inhuman longevity
his physical and mental health are
estimated to have begun deteriorating
with age
several decades prior to coming into
foundation custody
scp-2032 is currently receiving daily
treatment
for moderate alzheimer's and mild
dementia along with physical therapy for
arthritis
scp-2032 is now also undergoing speech
therapy following a stroke
the cause of which is detailed in
addendum 2032
a the main anomalous quality of scp-2032
is that his memory directly affects the
general public's historical recollection
as scp-2032's memory begins to fade
numerous branching opinions on
historical events consisting of
conflicted accounts
or other inaccurate information appear
this loss goes so far as to directly
alter historical texts as well
scp-2032 has written several journals
to keep his memory accurate there is a
theorized safe zone from the reality
altering effects of scp-2032's memory
for any documents or persons within 3
meters of him
additionally as time passes and the
event becomes less current it is
considered to have reached scp-2032's
long-term memory
in which the public may not be informed
but scholars and historians
are when information passes from this
stage of memorization
it is considered lost
following the discovery of the safe zone
within scp-2032's presence
newspapers and other information are
placed in the containment cell
until they can be more appropriately
archived a team of foundation archivists
now works daily to write down scp-2032's
recollections
starting with the farthest memories the
journals in which these events are kept
are locked inside a safe inside a
cp-2032
cell to prevent the loss of this
information
the general global opinion and knowledge
of recent world events
creates new memories for scp-2032
these recollections have been described
to researchers as
hazy at best requiring outside
information for accurate clarity
while an event is happening yet not
understood mostly being speculation or
rumors
scp-2032 likens it to recalling a dream
scp-2032 will gradually gain more
clarity around this event
causing knowledge to become public
despite the impact on his mental health
scp-2032's knowledge of an event is not
what causes the public reaction
as more cultural factors affect the
private understanding collective areas
have of an event
the psychological reaction on scp-2032
becomes apparent scp-2030
is on a daily regimen of medication to
warn off the ongoing symptoms of his
mental deterioration
at the current rate of deterioration it
is predicted that
years all written history prior to 685
ce
will be lost ongoing research is
currently underway on how to slow this
degradation
and if possible reverse it requests to
utilize scp-500 have been denied
due to the likelihood of reversing the
amnestics used to remove traumatic
events
from scp-2032's memory in the time
following his stroke
see addendum 2032-a numerous protests
and conspiracy theories became widely
spread among the public until scp-2032's
conditions stabilized
the hypothetical effects of any further
potential damage to scp-2032's memory
could lead to a theoretical cy-class
global government destabilization
scenario
including a loss of all written and
remembered accounts of human history
despite the continual deterioration of
his mental state
scp-2032 does not seem to age on the
cellular level
through dna testing it has been
confirmed that scp-2032
does not suffer from telomere shortening
and has not visibly aged in the decades
since its initial containment
it has been proven theoretically
probable that scp-2032 has
reached his oldest biological age
already and will not continue to age
further
it has been discovered manipulating the
memory of scp-2032 will alter knowledge
of events
for the public but cannot alter the
actual series
of events all facts are changed to what
scp-2032 remembered
anything that happened to contradict
these facts still
happened yet cannot be acknowledged by
humans
following critical containment failures
scp-2032 is given selective amnestics
and implanted with false memories
to skew the public recollection of
events all
o5 ordered historical alterations are
written with a copy of documentation of
the original events
locked in a safe kept in scp-2032's
vicinity
in case it is ever deemed appropriate to
revert the changes
any staff personnel found to implant
false information into scp-2032's mind
will be interrogated as to the purpose
of their alteration
and subsequently terminated the log of
scp-2032's initial interview
follows interviewed
henceforth scp-2032
interviewer dr luken forward
subject contacted foundation personnel
claiming to be an anomaly
after asking authorities for protection
after considerable testing to verify his
claims
an interview was approved begin log
april 1994 10
25 am
mister if you can recall how and when
did your abilities
initially manifest abilities
uh the memories the memories were always
perfect
always all records matched what i recall
the caliper asked me personally to be
his historian
bastard could not remember which wife
warmed his bed each night
this was long ago yes i don't know the
day
we never i do not remember it
still my mind is strong and will remain
strong in sour i was overjoyed
yes i could have anything in the east i
desired
i could say anything i wish bastard
calif wouldn't even know
but i was honest all throughout
please focus on the details pertaining
to your abilities
i cannot remember my birth what man can
at some point the memories began to
stick
and you cannot forget
a man comes to your house demands
tribute and your father refuses
he beats him with a stick your father
complains to the sheriff and the bastard
does nothing no one cares about these
things
but you still remember them more clearly
than you remember important things
at some point the memories always
stick and what made you desire to
contact the foundation
bastard men snakes a lot of them
sharply dressed and clean-shaven they
came to me one day
they asked me to work for them i refused
politely of course
and they tripled their offer as if the
money was all that mattered
i noticed them following me for days
after
sometimes one man sometimes many
sticking to me like shadows
so you came to the foundation to request
assignment
god willing yes
i can think of worse things
end log closing statement
scp-2032's request to enter foundation
custody has been granted
following the interview he was
transported to site 6
3. the initial log of tests to determine
the scope of scp-2032's abilities follow
test scp-2032 is asked at length
about several historical battles he
claims to have participated in
effects all information provided proves
to be accurate without exception
even so far as the position of the
constellations during the night
remarks while scp-2032 may struggle to
recall
these details he is exceedingly correct
his physical condition and accounts of
the battles are deemed enough
to verify his claims test
scp-2032 is given selective amnestics to
test the scope of his ability to alter
the recollection of events that others
possess
effects all personnel who were not in
the testing room
forgot the events in question remarks
scp-2032's abilities are confirmed to
have a limited
safe zone test
scp-2032 is given a minor selective
amnestic
to forget the battle effects
all documents portraying the events of
the battle save for those contained in a
safe
immediately near scp-2032 are rendered
blank
historians questioned about the battle
claim no such skirmish ever happened
matching those details remarks
scp-2032's memory appears to be a direct
master copy of history
whenever he forgets something it is
effectively erased
addendum 2032 a
on november 6th 1963 immediately
following the self-immolation of tick
duck at the apex of opposition towards
the vietnam war
scp-2032 had a moderate stroke
scp-2032 was given class b selective
amnestics
and implanted skewed facts to lessen
public outcry
preventing a worsening of his condition
addendum 2032 b
to prevent further complications to
scp-2032's health like those in 2032-a
o5 has approved selective amnestics to
be given to scp-2032
for any global events which may cause
public outcry
or mass hysteria
this concludes today's lecture thank you
for listening
if indeed you still are and you were all
dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to onix
arbiter seoul the morrigan
retalias karim el ashmoy
patrick bailey dreams
boy that ain't right matthew gilmore
eric corbidge kawaii fire keeper
joker corvus king madding
james saba and nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
vogue
thank you
you